like red balance okay yeah so uh so this
is what i said i was talking about but
i'm actually not gonna talk about this
it's uh
you know like
a month ago whenever i sent my abstract
uh i assumed things would be written up
and on archive by now and uh
uh the price to pay for optimism
um anyway it's uh it's coming soon
but um okay so
instead i'm gonna talk about this um
this other work which
is um
i'm really excited about it so i'll talk
about sort of what's
um
uh some previous work which kind of
sets the stage for hopefully a lot more
work um so
so anyway so i hope you excuse the
substitution of this talk for what i was
originally hoping to tell you about but
um but anyway
um okay so um towards instance optimal
testing and learning
um
okay so right so the basic setting you
know in general when one thinks of
testing or estimation of properties of
distributions um
you want to know well how many samples
are necessary to maybe learn a
distribution
to estimate a property value of the
distribution or maybe do some hypothesis
testing to test whether say the
distribution possesses some property of
interest
um
okay so
this is like a huge caricature and i
don't want to defend anyone i'm sure i
will but um so again the theoretical
computer science view
of these problems has been trying to get
tight
worst case bounds for various classes of
distributions for various of these
problems but these are worse worst case
over some
you know some sets of distributions
and worst case kind of in some
non-asthmatic regime okay so you have
some fixed distribution
parametrized by something or other and
what can you say
you know there are tons of exceptions
but
certainly the old statistics view is
the goal is slightly different so
optimal asymptotic
rates of convergence so there you're
saying we fix some distribution and we
want to design algorithms that as the
number of samples you draw kind of gets
large at least in asthmatic sense you
should be doing something optimal
okay um and you know both of these
perspectives has offered us
great results good insights on how to
actually get things to work well um
okay so what i want to try to push which
is you know
uh
maybe impossible in some settings
certainly a bit naive but um so what do
we really want well we kind of want some
sense of instance optimal performance
so we'd certainly like to understand the
sample complexities of the tasks we care
about
um i'll have an instance by instance
basis and they'll you know give one very
concrete example of what that means
but you know as opposed to asymptotic
rates of convergence as opposed to worst
case over various classes we'd like to
know kind of on every instance
what's going
on and we'd also like to develop
algorithms
um
which leverage whatever structure is
present in the instance
um but we don't want them to need to
assume prior knowledge of that structure
okay so that you give them some
you give them your samples they should
be able to figure out what structure is
there and leverage it
um but not know ahead of time okay so
these are both
uh you know
optimistic and a bit naive okay but um
um but you know
that's am i so um
okay so just to give one one
so very concrete
um
illustration of kind of this this sort
of approach which falls slightly shy of
this lofty goal okay but i'll give a
sort of extended description of this one
setting so
okay hypothesis testing for
distributions okay extremely basic
problem we're given some epsilon greater
than zero
and someone comes and tells you a
distribution p
so they say i have a big bag of jelly
beans i tell you
p1 there are ten percent of the jelly
beans are blue
five percent of the jelly beans are red
30 of the jelly beans are green okay
someone comes and describes the
distribution to you
and then you get to draw samples from
this
unknown distribution and your job is
just to decide is the distribution equal
to what i told you it should be
or is it far is the distribution of
jelly beans different from what i
promised you it was
far say in total variation distance okay
um
basic hypothesis testing well any
okay so so what's known about this um
you know so i mean this is
um
an instantiation of the kind of stuff
that even pearson was working on you
know a century ago
um
and
you know in the
tcs communities this work of about you
at all
um
basically showed that if you have a
distribution that's over support size at
most n
then you basically only need an order of
square root n samples to do this
hypothesis testing okay um and the
intuition here is kind of a birthday
paradox right so
um
look at the yeah the intuition is you
don't really need to see the whole
distribution all you need to do is start
to have some sense of kind of
uh
how many collisions are going on and
then you can already start to deduce
is this distribution actually what it's
meant to be or not
um
okay so
one specific distribution that people
care about is testing uniformity so
if you
unknown distribution you want to say is
it the uniform distribution over n
things or is it far from that okay so
goldright and ron we're looking at this
problem
and they also showed okay this root n
over some
poly epsilon dependence and the right
answer for testing the uniform
distribution is this root n over epsilon
squared okay so peninsula showed this
and this really
this really is just the birthday paradox
okay um
you know among distributions supported
on n things
the
uniform distribution minimizes the
number of collisions
so once you start to see some collisions
then you kind of can count how many
collisions you've seen and you basically
know is it uniform or not okay
that's
what's going on here
um
and okay so these are nice results these
are some specific distribution results
these are some worst case over some
class of distribution result
um
so you're saying faninsky is tight yes
yeah um and um
you know what we'd really like to know
is well
um cam what does this curve look like
for different distributions if i give
you an easy distribution if i you know
um
if i describe some slightly easier
distribution
you'd like to know how do you leverage
what this distribution is to design a
better test and to actually figure out
you know exactly what the sample
complexity is for this specific task
okay instead of some worst case or some
specific results um
okay so so this is what we do so um
so we show that there exists some fixed
function f it's a function of the
distrib of the distribution you
described
and epsilon
and they're constants and our tester can
distinguish the case that you know the
unknown distribution is equal to this
thing that was described versus the case
out there far
using this f of p com epsilon
samples um and no tester can distinguish
this using
um
kind of up to constants
more samples okay
and yes we're losing constants both in
front of the epsilon and in front of the
f
this is necessary for not so subtle
reasons but um
but okay um
okay so what is this function f um
so you know it's slightly ugly but it's
it's uh
it's not that ugly and it's surprisingly
clean given that you know
it's optimal to constant factors both
these terms are necessary and so on so
so what is this
well it's a max of one over epsilon okay
you certainly can't hope to do this
using fewer than one over epsilon
samples
it's a max of this term and the second
term
which is basically the two-thirds norm
of the vector of probabilities
after you've removed the largest
probability
and you've moved all of the small
probabilities
up until you've taken away epsilon mass
okay
um
okay so this is and we'll parse this a
little bit
um
okay so just you know one one thing to
note um
you know this expression this is this is
always at most just the two-thirds norm
of the vector p so immediately if p is a
distribution supported on most n
elements you know the two-thirds norm is
at most root n
um and so immediately this shows
actually this root n over epsilon
squared so peninski's tight result for
the uniform distribution this is worst
case
bound for all distributions supported on
at most n elements okay
but you know for easy distributions this
will get you lower sample complexity
is this like the worst case scale
divergence
uh no no so um so i'll give you a bit of
intuition where this comes from but um i
guess it's in hypothesis testing that
usually pops up um yeah although there
it's kind of
um
so there's usually you're saying you
know is it this thing or that thing here
we're saying is it this thing or is it
far from this thing right and so now
it's you know is it this one close to
this one distribution or is it you know
part of this huge set of distributions
so that's why it's that i mean that's
the difficulty
the question do you record
do you record the tester that it knows
um
uh it actually
so the question was do you require that
the tester knows that it knows
and and the point is um
uh
given this number of samples it will
um so it doesn't but it doesn't
the tester can't compute this number
right because it depends on p no no so
so you know p so i tell you there's a
mystery bag sorry so p p isn't the
mystery distribution p is
yeah yes right
um sorry
previous
one
so so the blue light should actually
just touch the magenta line or
uh so the blue is i mean it's not so
basically i mean it's not tight this
poly log isn't there
the yeah so so you know our results
imply that actually the blue line can be
improved to root n over epsilon squared
yeah yeah yes yeah
yeah
if you require a tester to accept also
when the two distributions are closed
within epsilon prime because
these do these methods generally um yeah
so so that that gets much harder so
um right so
um
yeah so
you know root n over epsilon squared
samples for any distribution supported
on n things you can you can test are
they equal or far from equal
if you want to test is there distance
less than 0.01
versus is there distance more than point
you know nine nine
there you actually need like n over log
n samples over if your distribution
supported on most n things
okay so so the one-sided versus
two-sided error is actually very
different it's almost this quadratic
um
okay so i'll actually tell you the the
test that
that achieves this and it's something
very intuitive
um it's actually very similar to
pearson's chi-squared test okay so
pearson's chi-square test is a
you know it's a very general very
general tool and in this specific for
this specific problem we're going to
make a
two slight tweaks to it and we'll
actually achieve this kind of
in some sense instance optimal testing
okay so again so someone describes the
distribution p to you you take some
samples from distribution q
let x i be the number of times you've
seen the ith element
so
both these tests are basically saying
look at the difference between the
number of times you see the ith element
and the expected number of times you've
seen it
square this
and subtract something like the expected
number of times you're going to see this
and divide by pi okay so
so this term and the denominator these
are deterministic okay i've written it
this way just because uh
basically we're going to replace this
by its expectation
sorry by its
you know the random variable who has the
same expectation namely x i kind of in
the good case
okay and instead of normalizing by pi we
normalize by pi to the two thirds
so what are the what's the intuition
behind these
things um
so in the case where the true where
we're actually taking samples from p
replacing this by x i doesn't change the
expectation of this quantity okay
um but the claim is it really reduces
the variance
so why is this well
most of your variance comes from very
rare elements okay so the intuition is
how many samples do you need well you
take samples and then you should stop at
the right time
and you should be able to stop when
there's still lots of things that you've
only seen once and twice right
otherwise you've taken way too many
samples
so most of the variants will come from
things you've seen zero times or one
time you know things that you might see
but probably won't see and the point is
if the expected number of times you're
going to see the i thing is very small
if this k times pi is almost zero
then this is like x i squared minus x i
which is basically zero if x i is either
zero or one
so you pay nothing for things you've
seen either zero or one times
whereas in this case
if there's something that's rather rare
you probably won't see it
if you do see it then this this really
kills you because now this is like you
know a 1 squared over pi this really
hurts
okay so
this first substitution is to decrease
the variance
um
okay the second that's normalizing by
the two-thirds power this is a bit more
subtle
um
so basically says look you know you see
some things some things appear more
likely more often than you'd expect some
appear less
how to what extent should you be
weighing um so if i see something that
you know differs from my expectation
um and i see it many times i should care
a lot about this so if some if someone
says look half the jelly beans are red
and the empirical number of jelly beans
i see is very different from 50
i should be troubled right
if someone says oh this jelly bean
occurs it's probably one over 100.
you know i'm more willing to tolerate
errors in the light elements
and that's what this two-thirds reflects
that i'm a bit more understanding of
deviations from the expectation for
elements that don't appear very often
okay and the intuition for white is
exactly two-thirds um there's no good
intuition
if you try to think about this problem
from the point of view of upper bounds
um
you end up with kind of thinking that
you should get some one exponent from
the point of view of lower bounds you
get a different exponent
so yeah so this count comes out of the
proof
um
all right so um
so how do you analyze this sort of thing
um
well you know conceptually it's very
easy so it's going to be an application
of chebyshev's inequality okay so we
have some we have some
um we have some
some quantity we want to analyze its
expectation its variance and so on right
um
so when you try to do it you end up with
sort of inequalities that basically look
like this
so these are
um
you know these these are pretty ugly
it's conceivable that you'll be able to
try to prove it but it's not gonna it's
not gonna make for a nice
for nice paper um
so the next part of the talk i was just
gonna mention this analysis tool which
basically turns this into just
an automated thing you just press enter
it tells you how to prove this done
and i wanted to mention it here because
you know
we've we've all sorted through this sort
of thing it's not fun and you know maybe
now you don't need to
what order are we supposed to be
well okay so this is the thing right
right so so uh yeah yeah so
uh so someone like you can probably just
march through this but uh no no but
but um
but yeah
it's the sum of those two
sorry there's a plus sign here that's
what you're asking
is less than the thing on the right yes
that's what you need to prove to argue
that the test will work it's a good
probability
um okay so i haven't mentioned lower
bounds so we have matching lower bounds
right the soft maldi thing it's some
hellinger distance stuff there are some
tricks but um
i thought i would mention this instead
since it's a bit more um
no i mean you know so my yeah so this is
work with my brother um we split up he
worked on lower bounds i worked upper
bounds um you know after
you know after two weeks we reconnected
he said no it's the one half norm i said
no it's a fifth storm and we're both
wrong for sort of dual reasons
and yeah so
um
if someone has a good intuition for i
should be two-thirds i would uh i would
like to hear it
one side doesn't work but if i make it
two-thirds plus delta
then the theorem's not true um yeah then
either the tightness or the
i sorry i can't figure
the convexity of these things i'm not
good at doing on the spot but yeah um
either the lower bound just ceases to be
tighter or the upper bound
um okay so i'll quickly tell you about
this um
yeah um but uh
yeah but it ceases to be tight for some
distributions yeah but whereas we want
to be tight for kind of everything
um so you can think of this as also so
some say someone tells you listen we're
gonna you know everyone likes the blue
jelly beans but uh but you know they
cost more since the blue dye is
expensive so
you know and blue ones are rare
so let's trick them we'll tell them it's
10 blue but we're actually going to add
you know fewer blue jelly beans and the
question is how much
how much can you
play with the probabilities without me
noticing
so if something is meant to appear half
the time you can't play with that
probability too much something's meant
to appear only ten percent of the time
you can play with that probability more
some things only appears one percent of
the time like relative to one percent
you can play with that probability a lot
and the question is how much
you know how does this uh
amount of play decay
or or how does it the relative amount of
play increase as it probably just gets
small and it's exactly this two-thirds
norm
so that's the kind of dual
interpretation as how do you design a
tricky thing that you're not going to
notice how much error can i stuff in
without someone finding out
four minutes okay
okay um
okay so uh
you know clear your head for a sec and
consider the following question
sure math question say someone gives you
a sequence three sequences sequence of
a's b's and c's
and they ask you is it true that for all
positive sequences x
j and y j
this inequality holds the product over i
of the sum over j of the x j is to the
a's y's to the b's the whole thing to
the c's when is this always greater than
one
so i claim that actually a lot of the
inequalities we know and love fall into
this class
okay so koshi schwartz has this form
right you pick a to be the vector one
zero half b is zero one and a half c is
half half minus one
this turns into this product which is
koshy schwartz
holder's inequality also has this form
you just replace the halves by you know
lambdas this by 1 minus lambdas and so
on
um what other inequalities have this
form
so it turns out this um this kind of
monotonicity of the lp norm has this
form just the fact that you know x plus
y squared
is uh
is greater than x squared plus y squared
okay
um right so that also has this form
what other things have this form well we
can multiply any of these and we have
other true inequalities of this form
is there anything else
and the answer is no
so
this thing is true for all positive
sequences if and only if
you can express this as a finite product
of holder type inequalities and lp
monotonicity inequalities
and so we show that actually
um we give it this algorithmic
characterization so if it's true we can
efficiently tell you how to prove it how
to decompose it into holder and
ultimate misty things and if it's false
we can efficiently find you a witness
which is a bit surprising because you
know i can describe one of these things
with
sequences a isbi cis of bit length
n such that the shortest counter-example
sequences
have like doubly exponentially many
terms
okay so maybe i'll yeah so i'll quickly
do this geometric interpretation of the
theorem i won't tell you how to prove it
i'll do this nice geometric
interpretation
so what does it mean then i mean to be
efficient i mean so it's construction
matter than actually you give me the
sequence because even storing that
sequence would be very yeah so it tells
you sort of how you could write it out
it gives you a witness to the existence
of it yeah
um
by the way there's matlab code that on
our websites that does this you just
enter in the asbs and sees it tells you
how if it's true and it and if it is it
tells you how to prove it that this is
what we use to write up our paper like
it's super easy um
so first though i want to just give you
this
geometric interpretation and this might
be i'll have time for
so say you want to prove this inequality
for all positive sequences x's and y's
this is true
this actually is one of the components
of this
thing that we needed to prove
so let's just plot these things on the
plane the
exponent of x is the x-coordinate
exponent of y is the y-coordinate
the weight is the exponent outside
so the theorem can be interpreted as
saying that this inequality is always
true if and only if we can zero out all
of these values
via two types of moves
so the holder type move where we can
take any two
positive numbers and we can move them to
their weighted weighted average
and then alpe montnistie thing
where we can slide any negative value
towards the origin and increase its
weight
okay so let's play this game
so what should our first move be
well you know we have these two positive
numbers
some negative thing in between them so
you know we can
take one unit of each of their mass
so this is and move it to their weighted
average we cancel out the negative thing
now what should we do
we want to make everything disappear
yeah so let's get rid of this namely
let's slide it on the line towards the
origin
and scale up its mass
okay so these are the this is a
holdering quality this is lp nisty thing
corresponding to these moves
okay now we have these three collinear
things and lo and behold uh if we move
the two outsides the middle
all of them vanish and lo and behold if
we multiply these three things
if we multiply these three equations we
get exactly this so we've proved our
inequality
and in some sense our theorem shows that
you know there's an efficient algorithm
for deciding how to win this game if
it's winnable
okay and even though they're an infinite
number of moves intuitively kind of only
a
finite number of them really make sense
right
okay so i guess i'm i'll skip the proof
of this
um
and i'll just end with yeah so further
directions um
so this this characterization of these
inequalities applies to sequences of two
things
what happens if you have more positive
sequences
and the answer is the exact same
characterization holds um
yeah it's it's uh it's quite a robust
phenomena and it seems to be new in part
in part because the
the proof is very algorithmic so it's a
little different from the usual math the
proofs of this sort of thing
um
and this going back to this instance
optimal property estimation and learning
so the setting i described this
hypothesis testing is sort of easy
because i'm telling you
this distribution p and then you get to
tailor your algorithm for that for that
instance so it's not as instance optimal
as one would hope
but you know more general settings
it still might be possible we have some
results that
hopefully will be ready to be discussed
in the next week
um that are kind of really nice and
anyway so um
in general if you can do some instance
optimal sort of algorithm it's likely to
have a nice theory and it's also likely
to work quite well in practice and so
that's kind of the
uh
so maybe i'll end there
so we'll take a quick question while the
next video
and of course i'm sure many of you have
many more questions which we'll save for
the discussion section so yes thank you
yes
on that point about knowledge of p yes
which is very similar but suppose i give
you two sequence
and it asks you whether they're from the
same distribution
or they're from two different
distributions different by more than one
right so so then the
um
so you can define some some analogous
sort of instance optimal sort of setting
where you where you'd want to say
something like um
you'd like to do at least as well as
um
as if i had almost described this
distribution to you so say i tell you
that i i describe some distribution
that's close to
that's close to the true distribution
ahead of time and you hope to do as well
as if you know you actually had known
this
right elon wants to say something i
think uh this quote this problem is
talking about closeness testing
and yeah
right okay you have some negative
results right
so we have if we can show that you can
do fastness testing we have the
boundaries
and
also for classification what you call
instance for instance we call are
competitive
so for that common the more complicated
seal pump that you have two training
sequences and you have a test sequence
you can also do that
um
but so there though so you do lose
something right so the competitiveness
that are independent of dominant size
regardless of what your support size is
and we also show that everyone has to
lose you cannot be optimal everywhere
yeah yeah and whatever you can do we
also show some positive results so you
can achieve